the Joe Rogan experience that's why I
think for a lot of guys you know walking
into an MMA gym it's terrifying but it's
ok everything start with you know one
tiny step and I like I like doing
anything that makes me feel
uncomfortable and and and takes me off
my pins and huge because I it opens up
new pathways of understanding somehow or
it certainly forces me to so what I do
now with people who I disagree with
philosophically you know like say I'm
talking to somebody is a hardcore
socialist or something like that
it's okay but what I what I try to do is
I just try to listen to them really but
I try to kind of zero in instead of like
immediately throwing my hands up did you
see what Britney Cummings said the other
day
Britney Cummings written written Whitney
coming no did I say Britney you know I
think I was slobbering it's okay too
much of that chimeric got American
coffee but I guess people say why you
coughing so much I don't want to tell
the truth it's to merit coffee you know
[ __ ] what was I just saying you said
what Whitney Cummings oh she got
reported to HR on a show she was on cuz
as she was leaving she said Merry
Christmas some intern no yes intern was
offended it's called human resources
because she said Merry Christmas and her
response was hey I really don't give a
[ __ ] if you have a good Christmas it's
just a nice thing to say
yeah I gotta give a [ __ ] about your
Christmas I don't even know you like
something that's reported or that that's
something that's very [ __ ] important
for people to realize about the West
something that's really unique about the
West and Western civilization is that
imperialism racism sexism all these isms
that we are guilty of well the West
didn't invent these things but we did
you know we were egregious violators in
some cases of that you know slavery was
a real thing in this country but what's
what's unique about the West and I'm
getting this thing is that we were the
first to label it and condemn it and the
West has always been a country that
seems always to be in the process of
repenting for its past
dancing for instance that is not common
that is unique to and self-criticism is
part of it as a society we are so people
like that silly girl who that's been
going on actually in one way or another
for a long time now it's the intern yes
now it's way more enough was a girl or
boy right now no it's a little bit more
it's it's way more but but that's
actually to the character of this
country we have always had people who
kind of went mad uh you know that's
wrong I don't want to do that the this
is this isn't fair all that kind of
stuff
and it was a [ __ ] it would always
cause all kinds of problems but that's
extreme that's a silly goose whoever is
doing that is well it's Hollywood
there's a Hollywood thing where these
people can't be liberal enough they're
trying so hard to be progressive that
they just become a ridiculous yeah and
they get so reactionary and everyone's
scared that they're gonna be out of the
woke loop like maybe they're behind
they're letting something slide they
should have stepped up for cuz now you
can get in trouble if you don't come out
against someone saying Merry Christmas
like hey man you know where were you
when that [ __ ] pig said Merry
Christmas do you know what Christmas
means yeah like do they want to take
away the word supremacy and quantum
supremacy which is quantum computing
it's next level next step computing and
yeah there was an article about Google
achieving quantum supremacy and they
were like well we don't like the term
supremacy because it reminds people of
white supremacy do you know what I think
about those people do you know anything
about a lot of people they're already
there they're not they're young they're
not experienced and they're not that
bright this is the thing is they are
bright they just aren't wise they're
very smart and they know they are which
is one of the reasons why they want to
make an argument to push something like
that through and think that it makes
sense it's because they're so smart but
what they're not is is you get seasoned
by your interactions with human beings
you're naive when you're younger and
then as you get older you get seasoned a
mind changes but you also get seasoned
meaning you experience so many different
human beings that exhibit these sort of
stereotypes
and these like patterns of behavior and
you got to know when people are being
knuckleheads and you've got to know when
people are being wise and objective and
you got to know when people are being
kind and loving and you got to know when
people are being [ __ ] so you can see
all the different things as you get
older you get more data you know and a
lot of these kids are like 20 no 22 and
you're yelling about the world like that
Greta Thornburg check the heat breaking
ever she's sixteen he's a kid listen
you've got some good points but this
they're using you well what happens is
as you get older and you try to solve
problems at the level of detail so if
you and I had to really solve some
problems let's say health care and if
you and I'm sitting here I'm not solvent
she if we had to try right what would
happen is we might come with more of a
Republican or Democratic or liberal or
conservative sensibility initially I
think once you get down the level of
detail and you're trying to solve these
problems all that II that ideology kind
of goes out the window because now
you're dealing with hard numbers and
math and you're trying to deal in
percentages and you're trying to deal
with what's the best policy for the most
number of people and so it becomes way
way grayer and way less teeny if you are
somebody that has to solve problems if
you are somebody who has to turn a
profit if you're somebody who has to
figure out what your pot what Europe
clientele actually will buy and I think
sometimes that's why people who own
businesses and and people who have to
make the trains run on time have a
different philosophical and political
point of view then do people who
essentially spend a lot of time reading
thinking and writing in an academic
institution right because you don't need
to get down to the level of detail you
can stay in that wonderful world of
theory and that's an important world
it's not to say that you shouldn't have
that but a lot of journalists come from
that world they come straight from that
world of theory that world of that
intellectual pursuit and and they come
right into then they see the world and I
think that might be why a lot of times
people in the media tend to be a little
bit more ideological maybe a little bit
more liberal depending because you could
say
News is just as [ __ ] ideological on
the other side but I do think your your
perspective changes when you have to get
down to when you're in the real world
yes yeah no it's both though yeah right
and this is what what I think we need to
make this distinction like you need
these quantum theorists you need these
historians you need these people that
are just completely yeah engaged in
whatever the subject is yeah and you
know and they're just lifelong academics
and this is well yeah but what the real
problem is when people come out of these
universities and they have these sort of
hard blind ideas of how the world needs
to change
they're revolutionaries yeah yeah and
they there's it's very exciting yeah
it's very exciting so they want to burn
down the whole bill and that's what you
start looking for witches okay and then
you start going that [ __ ] said Merry
Christmas yeah and that's what that is
yeah that's what's nuts Google's calling
it quantum supremacy can you [ __ ]
believe this [ __ ] yeah we gotta break it
down back down there yeah it's a lot of
it as being young but young people can
do some when they get together and that
the Communist revolution was you know
this is also what discourse is so
important right like young people need
to talk to other people you know I like
a lot of these people with these ideas
are one day on the laugh at those ideas
they're one gonna look back go oh my god
when I was 20 I was so stupid just like
you have done just like I have done just
like basically everybody does is they
get older you start thinking oh my god
when I was 18 what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
oh my god when I was 24 you only hear
the stupid [ __ ] I thought I should do I
mean that's part of life
[Applause]